hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the paul
morphy saga and here uh he faces a most
dangerous opponent his german
grandmaster daniel harvitz and he
arrived
in paris and at the moment when he
arrived morphe immediately asked if he
would be interested in having a match
against morphy
but harvest declined and morphy was uh
well borderline furious because he
couldn't get a match with staunton now
he arrives here to challenge uh
all the best players here now he gets
the decline from from horowitz
but then uh as the crowd learned that
there could be a match between morphy
and harvest the crowd started
also cheering uh and the harvest um uh
started reconsidering whether to
actually accept the the match uh
for morphe or not and the first he asked
whether uh morphe was interested in
playing one
a casual game uh before he decides
whether he wants to play against morphy
i guess that's how
they did uh things in those days and
morphe agreed and morphe actually lost
this game but uh it was
it was a pretty weird challenge harvard
said that morphy
uh uh will get the black pieces and
morphe has to
accept uh the king's gambit and the
harvest obviously uh
a great uh uh well
uh a possessor of knowledge regarding
the
the king's gambit uh was uh able to win
this game now i did not know that this
game actually exists uh
or or that the moves were recorded but
they were so i'm sorry i'm not
presenting this game
first but i'm going to present this game
in the in the in the other video because
i already prepared this one
but this is actually the first game of
their match uh so later after winning
that game harvest agreed to a game
and uh they agreed to some terms first
they had to decide whether they're going
to have seconds where
whether there is going to be an umpire
whether they're going to play
um a match for money even though we all
know morphy was not allowed to do that
by by command of his family uh but
morphy still said that uh it doesn't
matter that harvest does not have any
backers as of yet but
morphy said that at any point in the
match whether harvest uh finds any
backers or it doesn't matter
how much money uh he puts up uh morphy
will
uh will put up just just as much so in
the end the match was decided to be
played for 295
francs uh so if any of you guys can do
some calculating
what kind of a what kind of cash are we
talking about
in today's terms you know if we take
into consideration inflation and
everything
would also be very nice because when i
do it you guys always say that i do it
wrong and then you write in the in the
comments that
no no it's actually like this so i would
very much appreciate it if if you did it
and then i can pin your comments so
everyone else can enjoy
so getting to this match we are going to
going to discuss a little bit of
specifics
um uh regarding some stuff during the
match but now let's just check out the
game
and also i would just like to mention
that daniel harvest uh had a
uh had a very famous match against love
intel and the the match was actually
organized
by none other than howard staunton and
uh harvest won that match but it was
really funny because um
elemental was leading like nine to one
and then
in the end the the match ended by
harvest winning uh i think 11 to 10 so
it was pretty crazy
and i think staunton definitely had
something
going on in there maybe even a bit or
something because he was uh
incredibly upset with with love and tall
and uh
he uh he he never forgave him for for
this great betrayal
so to say uh so there's a you know a lot
of stuff that we don't know
but okay getting uh to this game morphe
now has the white pieces and this is the
first game of the match morphe harvest
of the nine
of the 1858 match in paris so let's see
how it went morphe with the white pieces
opens with e4
and i would just uh like to mention that
this is quite the game so i'm sure
you're going to enjoy
it we have e5 by harvest knight to f3
and d6 we are in france so why not go
for the for the philidor's defense we
have d4
morph immediately strikes in the center
and now e captures on d4 and morphy
plays queen captures on d4
morphy was also a very big fan of
sacrificing pawns with something like c3
captures and captures but i guess he
kind of respects harvey's uh not not to
go for it
this game and also it's not very good in
this line like it's it's very much
playable in the scotch but maybe here
it would be a bit too much so here queen
captures on d4 by morphe
uh knight to c6 attacking morphy's queen
and now
bishop to b5 pinning that knight so the
queen cannot be captured we have bishop
to d7
and now bishop captures in c6 with
bishop captures on c6
and we get this position that um uh
this game was played in 1848 and this
position uh
stood the test of time alien became uh
i played this position a lot with white
and even i found the game between uh
alexander chabal of uh and uh with the
great attacker larry christianensen from
the
from last year from 2020 in the u.s
senior championship where
shabalov won a very nice game with the
white pieces in this line so
definitely stood the test of time as you
know even even with
today's engines uh it's still okay so
here uh and the knights the c3
would be played today but okay in those
days bishop to g5 by morphe
of course over the course of some 150
years uh
uh modern theory and engines improved
all the lines to to perfection so here
bishop to g5 attacking the queen
knight to f6 just continuing development
preparing bishop to e7 and castles and
now
knight to c3 we have bishop to e7
and the morphe now castles queen side
morphe often was a huge fan
of uh opposite side castles because then
you could freely push your pawns and
attack your opponent's king side
we have kingside castle and now rook
h2e1
and morphy is now fully developed the
knights the bishop
is here the rooks are fully operational
here also controlling the dnd file
but one thing you have to notice is that
morphe no longer has the bishop pair so
let's see how this goes with h6 asking
more if you do want to retreat or do you
want to capture here
uh morphe retreats once and now knight
the e8 offering a trade of dark square
bishop so morphy has to choose whether
where to go back whether to trade
whether maybe some e5
uh action is possible here uh but okay
morphe goes for bishop captures on e7 it
is the
it is perfectly fine queen captures and
now we have
e5 and this position has never been
reached again
as of as of move 13. and it's very
interesting this e5 idea is uh
uh is one of the the strongest moves in
the position there is a
game from 2005 where knight the d5 was
played but the e5
is definitely better here so here uh
black needs to now uh figure out what to
do the rooks are obviously going to
become extremely powerful if the
if these two pawns disappear so here
first the bishop captures on f3
eliminating one of uh one of uh morphy's
pieces doubling up his pawns
and also not being afraid of opening up
the g file so let's see how this goes uh
and
you you can do an in between move uh
like a nice fishing suit here with e
captures and d6
like open up an attack on the queen and
you're going to capture the bishop
next because just check and then you you
uh you have to react to this and then
you're also going to lose uh
material here or yeah you could also
play just rook d2 but then just a queen
captures and you don't get to recapture
the bishop so same stuff
so after bishop captures morphy has to
recapture and now we have queen to g5
check king b1 always useful move uh and
now
d captures on e5 we have rook captures
on e5 attacking the queen and now
queen to g2 is still keeping an eye on
the g1 square not allowing morphe to
uh get his rook over to the g1 square
because then
he would be able to uh well put a lot of
pressure on black's king's side
so here knight to d5 morphe happily
brings yet another attacker into the
attack uh
saying that black doesn't really have a
good move you can't really go something
like this because just
check and you will you will lose that
that rook uh
and other than that you don't really
have many active moves so here black
just uh calmly plays
uh queen captures on h2 grabs a pawn and
it seems
completely crazy to do something like
this in in this position
uh but it's uh very hard for uh for
morphe to find the move uh but there is
one move that stands out but it's an
extremely hard move to find so i'm not
gonna ask you to pause the video
uh because it's just super weird uh here
uh morphe played uh
rogue back to e1 because he really wants
to get the rooks over to the g and h
file
but here f4 was actually extremely
strong the idea behind f4
is that you want to prevent the queen
from uh going anywhere on this diagonal
and now
next you want to play rook to e1 and
then start harassing that queen because
the white queen covers the f4 and f2
pawns
so something maybe to consider uh but
uh probably morphy was uh not uh
still not ready to play at his best
because it's it's only the first game
and there's really no good move here for
black i mean you you could start pushing
those pawns on the queen side but white
should definitely be faster
uh so instead after this uh queen
captures an h2 this was not played
morphy
started with rook to e1 now preparing to
shift the rooks to the g and h file
but now queen back to d6 and this is a
really active move for the black queen
which could have been prevented with a
move like f4
and okay rook to g1 now morphy has some
incredible pressure here along the
uh g file and this diagonal king the h7
getting out of uh any unnecessary knight
checks
uh so okay you you still have access
with knight to f6 check but it's not as
potent
so here we have queen to e3 by morphe
and now again what do you do you don't
really have any good
discoveries with the knight but here uh
black could uh very well just play
knight to f6
offer offer that everything gets traded
off and even if white goes knight to e7
opens up a discovery towards the black
queen
after queen e6 there's not much white
can do here for example queen d3 check
king h8
and now rook d to e1 yes you don't have
to trade but now after queen to b6
it is a completely unclear position
where
uh anything any anything could happen so
uh
this is this is one possibility but here
black instead went for f5 and it looks
um
very dangerous because you already
weakened the king's side now you play f5
so can morphy take advantage of this
well morphy starts with knights to f4
remaneuvers the knight
with an attack on the queen here we have
queen to b6 offering a queen trade
and morphy definitely not interested in
a queen trade it just moves the queen to
e2
uh so again it's very hard the blacks
rooks are not connected
uh the rook can come to d7 the queen can
come to e7 there can uh
you know a lot of pressure is uh being
put towards black's king's side
and here rook to f7 this is the absolute
strongest defensive idea and it just
shows you how strong harvest is
uh because one could easily uh blunder
the game completely by let's say
you just look at your position you say
okay my rooks are not connected let's
just start with knight f6 and then we're
going to develop
but the problem is then queen e7 and
you're completely destroyed this is the
threat of checkmate
after you block this you start bringing
more attackers into the game
and now once you defend this one more
time for example queen f7
and that's uh that's game the rook is
coming to g6 and
it's simply too much pressure for black
to handle just to show you how
funny a position is for example if king
h8 rook to g6 now
one more defender and also uh preparing
rook captures and h6
after you make this rook lift and now
there's not much for
for black to do whatever you play let's
say you bring a rook into the game just
rook to d7
and that's it pretty crazy position
black can play whatever
threat and checkmate but then you just
deliver this check and it's game over
for example captures and the queen to h7
checkmate
so this is what is in the position uh
but okay after queen to e2
like we said a harvest goes for the
absolute best defensive idea rook to f7
and now morphe starts by improving the
position of his pieces queen c4
with an attack on this rook and now
queen to f6
bringing the queen back here to help out
with the defense we have knight to h5
attacking the queen putting more
pressure on g7 and now queen to e7 this
is the only move because otherwise you
you lose the rook so queen to e7
the only possible move for black and now
rook d to e1
again chasing away the black queen queen
to d7
and now morphe wants to start uh lifting
those those rooks but he has
some back rank issues if the rooks get
away from the background queen d1 is
checkmate
so morphe decides to waste the move by
playing a3 and now okay his king
gets a breeding square here on on a2 and
uh now he's gonna start
bringing those rooks into the game but
this also means that black now gets an
extra move to help out with the defense
so knight to d6
uh which tempo the queen is under attack
so queen to d4
and now with a triple attack here but
it's fine it's defended three times
and now again black with the absolute
best rook
rook the g8 and this is pretty crazy uh
again you could easily blunder the game
here just to show you how sensitive the
position is with something like rook to
e8 you say you want to trade some pieces
here
but then you run into rook captures on
g7 with
check uh point is that after rook
captures knight f6 check picks up the
queen
and now you would be able to capture the
queen because you don't care about this
you've played a3 and you don't have to
be worried about any back rank issues
so here after queen to d4 rook the g8
again
harvest playing the absolute monstrosity
of a defense
uh rook to g8 and now morphy starts uh
well he he prepares with rook to g2 now
he can either double up on the g file or
he can play a rook to h one to
uh bring another attacker into the game
but now a harvest plays knight to e8 he
offers a queen trade
and it's uh not easy for morphe to
decline but morphe is not interested in
a queen trade morphe keeps the pressure
with queen to c3
but now the position is uh pretty bad
for morphe but it's
so difficult to find why the position is
uh well close to lost but that's where
you guys come in uh feel free to pause
the video here and try to find
the absolute best move for uh harvest
while i give you a couple of seconds
it's not an easy one
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
f4 uh and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show yeah it's f4 and i
know what you're thinking like what's f4
i mean
what does f4 even do well what it does
is that it traps the knight on h5 it's
pretty crazy but
uh now this pawn is guarded you cannot
move the knight you can't bring the
knight here here and also it takes with
the g3 square from the knight so this is
this is insane uh to spot such a thing
this is what morphe missed and now he's
definitely in trouble
here morphy started with rook to h1
bringing
a rook to defend the knight but this
simply doesn't work i will
show you one possible defense but it's
so so uh
so disgusting that you know maybe maybe
i even shouldn't
uh point is you you should play rook to
e5 because it comes with a trick
g6 okay the knight cannot move and the
knight will be captured
but now queen to e1 and now the point is
if the knight is captured now you have
this
really really awesome queen to e4 check
and only after the king moves now you
eliminated the defender of the knight
with czech king captures and the rook
characters here with check
and now white will have a superior game
however uh this is not forced after
queen to e1
black of course will not capture the
knight black will just play the simple
knight the g7 and then okay morphe does
not lose a knight
we have something like captures captures
but black still
uh retains a better position he's up
upon and he has a better pawn structure
uh if anyone will be pushing for
something here it's definitely black so
uh it's a bad position but uh with rook
to e5 it
it uh maybe it will uh morph maybe
could could still save it but uh here
morphe played rook to h1 and now
uh simply it's just bad the g6 was
played instantly by harvest
i imagine uh and now uh rook h the g1
this is how morphy tries to keep his
piece now if captures then the rook
falls but now just
queen to d5 and now again the knight is
under attack the knight has no squares
and there's uh well really nothing you
can do here
queen to e1 was played by morphe he
prepares one last trick to maybe save
him
queen captures an h5 and now even rook
to g5
his idea was okay maybe if pawn captures
then rook to h1 i can win the queen
but still that's um black has too much
material even just capturing with
check it's still two rooks and the
knight against the queen with black
being up upon
in a better pawn structure it's uh it is
a lost position for morphe
but okay it's the first game so why not
uh you know at least
try how how harvest handles every in all
positions
so here uh harvest just played queen
captures an f3 it's
the best idea we have queen to e6 now
with a triple attack on the pawn here
but now rook to f6 everything is very
easily uh
defended here queen e7 check and now
even rook g7 offering the knight because
the rook falls
so here queen captures any eight there
really isn't anything better we have h
captures on g5 and now
queen uh back to e8 and here after
morphe played this
uh harvest just brought back the queen
with queen to c6
and it was in this position i moved 37
that paul murphy resigned in the game
and uh the first uh game of the match
goes to
daniel harvey's and what what a game it
was
so not only did he win the first one
that we are going to show
that's another part of the match it was
the game that actually uh
got harvested even play a match with
morphe because he okay he saw a king i
may
i i can play against this guy but now
morphy
loses the actual first official game of
the match so this is uh
definitely something new and we're gonna
have a lot of fun covering this match
but for the next video
uh we are showing the uh game that got
harvested to even or
you know grant morphy d the honor of
challenging him to a match
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it very weird to see morphe
starting with a loss but uh what are you
gonna do
uh i would like to thank veto nasimi uh
barry mcmurdock vince oshina berry uh
bruce t berger
and bob skoman who is celebrating his
60th birthday uh congratulations on that
achievement and thank you uh thank you
uh everyone for for the
hartley contributions uh so yeah
uh once again uh that's that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and uh
i i will see you guys like i said uh
we're gonna cover uh this game next and
it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and for those
of you who might have missed yesterday's
stream we had a lot of fun talking about
chess and physics with my friend andrei
dundovich so
if you if you're interested in checking
that out i will put a link to it in the
description below will be the the first
thing that you see thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day